on the next Rick and Morty it's
important Jerry the fate of the galaxy
rests on your shoulders let's go put
some pants on
Sunday at 11:30 my son asked you to take
me on some kind of kiddie adventure what
did you think it was an execution geez
you really do need a win only on Adult
Swim hey everybody is Charlie new record
warden let's break it down and there's a
new round of the merch giveaway and if
you're wondering I usually name giveaway
winners at the end of videos sometimes I
get questions about that
but as you can see Rick and Jerry
Adventure if this promo feels familiar
it's because it's a mirror of this scene
here going all the way back to the
beginning with a few less burps and a
few less spittle dripping off of Rick's
mouth
they've toned that down just a little
bit from that very first episode but I
recommend you go back and watch that
every once in a while because it's funny
to see how the show has changed over
time just the way they animate it in the
way that characters act but the episode
is called were leaderly conspiracies so
we actually know this is probably the
footage from the trailer that we've seen
with the two of them on the giant roller
coaster so it wouldn't be rick and morty
without some sort of conspiracy theory
aspect to the show but it looks like a
giant blitz and chips type episode where
rick is like okay let's go have some fun
while we inadvertently save the galaxy
like that's Rick's pitch to Jerry but he
probably doesn't care about saving the
galaxy at all like he seemed really
concerned about those bugs at the
beginning of last week's episode if
these get into the food chain that you
can kiss the human race goodbye you
might want to freeze some sperm Morty so
he sort of vacillates between blitz and
chips type moments where he just wants
to go have fun for an episode and then
very brief genuine moments of concern
like he's actually concerned to this
moment here but in this first episode
like this scene that this is a mirror of
he just wanted to go get these giant
seeds and he got way too drunk to do it
himself
and then just through the course
events it turns into a big crazy
adventure so it sounds like that's what
this episode is gonna be like even
though it has the runner of the divorce
I was surprised that last week's episode
The Vindicator SEPA sewed didn't have
too much divorce stuff in there it
almost felt like more of a standalone
episode but they did say that there
would be some of those this season it's
not going to be all completely
serialized but there's actually a bunch
more trailer moments that we've seen
from this coming episode just based on
the description here so it reads Rick
takes Jerry on an adventure at Morty's
insistence like he says I love that
twist this is a pity adventure isn't it
Marty told you to take me on an
adventure
then it says Beth fails is a mother and
summer has body issues so that's
probably what these scenes are from the
trailer literal body issues and that she
becomes super huge because Beth fails as
a mother and we might get this gene
scene too because this looks like it's
happening right in front of their house
mind your own goddamn business gene
everything okay here my damn business
gene so I'm actually really optimistic
about this episode I mean a Jerry
episode doesn't sound great it's almost
like Family Guy doing a mega episode
like they challenge you not to watch it
that was one of my favorite twists looks
like it's gonna be a mega episode I dare
you to change the channel here's the
clicker the good thing about episodes
like this though like the ones that
aren't a straight-up parody of some
other franchise is that they tend to be
a little bit better the episodes that
are just about family stuff they're just
said in the Rick and Morty universe I
mean I really love it when they parody
the other stuff that I watch but maybe
you guys will agree that the stories
just tend to be a little more meaningful
and a little bit stronger when they're
just about Rick and Morty stuff there
was a quote from Justin roiland I think
it was on one of the season one or
season 2 DVD commentaries where he
talked about how he jokingly parodies
other franchises
and usually by his own admission they
tend to just borrow big twists like they
don't openly try to parody too many
other franchises I think last week was
an exception because it was a genuine
parody of a couple really big franchises
including saw like all the Marvel in the
DC movies but let me know what you guys
think of the season so far and what do
you think of the way they've been using
this divorce is their big runner I mean
it's funny to think about what's going
on with Jerry but usually
he's used for Meg type twist like shut
up Meg shut up Jerry I know right they
typically use him as a punchline so
it'll be interesting to see how the
episode works when he becomes more of a
main character in the other characters
who are usually the main characters
become the background characters I've
seen a lot of people fifty-fifty on the
way they've done that with everybody
this season like summer and Beth you
know typically supporting characters are
more main characters this season some
people like that some people hate that
I've even seen the creator sort of
arguing with people on Twitter like some
people really don't like it so they'll
start going after Dan Harmon and the
other writers but I think it's just
natural for a show in its third season
to start focusing on characters that it
hasn't focused on in the past before you
still have your Morty Rick centric
episodes they're still the bedrock of
the TV show but I think in the way that
shows like The Simpsons have made it to
like 20-plus seasons they have to rely
on some of their other characters in
order to just build the universe out
more like you see terminator summer here
with regular summer on this galactic
government ship with the Garoppolo mines
I'm interested to see what they're doing
with the government now because they had
that big twist in the first episode
where Rick blew them up but I think that
was mostly to resolve that running
plotline like they're still after his
teleportation technology but I think it
was more to just allow them to start
doing family-centric episodes and not
have to worry about them every week and
that was really what happened at the end
of season two so they needed a
compelling reason for the galactic
government to leave earth and that was
Rick blowing them up so it's like okay
that's why they're not around every
single episode because Rick blew them up
but yes I do believe that Phoenix person
will come back but part of what I love
about the show is that they're so
ridiculous with their mythology like
that like maybe we won't bring this back
maybe this was just intended to be a
one-off really funny thing and we're not
gonna reference it again but I feel like
birdperson was such a big character
turning him into Phoenix person and then
never bringing him back would be way too
big of a slap in the face but I'm not
expecting him anytime soon
and when they do bring him back it'll
probably be for a bigger episode so like
the next time the government shows up is
probably when we'll hear about that
believe all your requests for bonus
videos in the comments somebody who has
started asking for Rick and Morty theory
videos so because we've gotten a couple
episodes there's a bunch of new material
I'll probably start doing those soon
especially when Game of Thrones finishes
its run and I'm not focusing on it quite
as much but just a reminder that Marvel
defenders is dropping on Friday I'll be
doing episode videos for that I'll do a
non-spoilery review tomorrow I have
another defenders trailer video that
I'll post next after this though so
whole bunch of Marvel stuff is happening
this weekend before Game of Thrones and
Rick and Morty comes back but be sure to
subscribe to get everything
all you have to do to enter the merch
giveaways just be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video the for Zen monkey
studios congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner tln please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
can click here for all my pickle Rick
Easter eggs and you can click here for
the trailer for next week's game of
Thrones thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]